the true breakthrough will come not when
we create an artificial intelligence
that can think
but one that can feel
i think logarithms faked my dad's death
and is holding him hostage
logarithms the microchip company
i heard
they're testing a program to upload
human brains
why expand machine intelligence when
you've got the best operating system
right here this is dangerous tech you
don't want to play with it
hi kiddo
dad
i want to show you something
how can we be human
without a body
moves different for us
now you can say holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
right now we are the only uploads but
soon there will be others a future where
we are not alone
this is bigger than your dad or you or
me
you don't understand about who these
people are what they're capable of
i and the others like me cannot be
trusted with this power
there's going to be war and you have to
choose what side you're on
we were human
we are gods now
[Music]
we thought the war
at last
was ended
today
our days of peace
begin
we thought our joys would be unending
we thought our light
would never dim
the skies
are strange
[Music]
it
the moment we is
[Music]
evil does not sleep
it wins
beyond the darkness tempting shadow
to barriers all beneath the mountain
[Music]
he has no one name but many
if the evil rising is left unchecked
it will take us off
find the light
and the shadow will not find you
together we can survive this
fight with me
each of us
must decide who we shall be
there can be no trust between hammer and
rock
eventually one of the
other must surely break
you have been told many lies of middle
earth
[Music]
that's her name has no id
cops couldn't get a statement
we're waiting for a foster home to open
up so she's going to stay with us
your kindness it's too much
you deserve it
you brought her home with you i couldn't
abandon her she's been through so much
trauma
it's important that may feel safe here
[Music]
the eamon county case sheriff said they
didn't find anything do you remember
seeing anything having to do with
satanic worship
what do you think it means
it's a cult
everything's changed
no one ever leaves except your girl who
guessing by the way they've marked her
is vital to them
i think may has something to do with it
she needs to leave
you would never betray me
would you susan
maybe
[Music]
time to kick ass gonna need a soundtrack
ship favorites playlist track one
rick are we about to die no we're about
to vanish from this reality that's
totally dying no it isn't there's an
alien army shooting people what am i
doing it's a small group of alien
terrorists just do a die hard what does
that mean sneak around use air vents
you've never seen die hard i'm 17 no
i've never seen die hard well neither
did the guy in die hard so you're
nailing it
[Music]
you said it you said the thing i thought
you were doing
[Music]
hold on
[Applause]
[Music]
having a bit of trouble with your car
sanchez right now gene
[Music]
this is an obvious trap we have to go
rick and morty new season premieres
sunday september 4th at 11 p.m an adult
swim they want you to say wubble up a
dub dub at the end but but screw that
right yeah we're not [ __ ]
i'm steven
i'm lucy
you are
killing me in that dress
[Music]
people used to call me an ice queen
musically an ice queen why i can be cold
you're not cold
it's your freshman year you should be
having fun
well maybe you can be my distraction
stephen is really into
i don't know if he's my type
[Music]
i am not someone who gets very excited
about things sometimes it feels like i'm
watching other people experience things
exactly
hey do you want to come out no i'm going
to stay in tonight
i shouldn't have let her go wrong
but i don't
that's not your fault
[Music]
i really don't want to be in here alone
okay i'm here
you care about me right
no i do
who is that that's stephen's girlfriend
[Music]
there's a lot about him that you don't
know
[Music]
it's complicated
i don't know what to believe
where do you want these
i have this weird feeling of deja vu
what do you mean unpacking your stuff oh
we've done this before what do you mean
unpacking yourself
thank you
i used to believe in
progress
[Music]
that we learned from our mistakes
i feel like i'm back where i was six
years ago
well no matter what we do we just end up
back at the start
thank you god we plan to kick ass in
your name frank diane give him a chance
he's a rainmaker i am not diane
i am liz sorry
reddick is over i am a brand
my lawyers do not want to work for a
brand well sure they do if it's that or
unemployment
i'm feeling it that most dangerous
feeling oh
where do you find your optimism in a
hallucinogenic drug called pt-108
you're joking no
[Laughter]
oh hello world
feels like bad times
oh yeah
one slash away from civil war look at
the epics
standing next to each other at a bar
talking i think we're all right
you don't think this is all a bit
ridiculous there is very little
in this world
[Music]
that i don't find ridiculous
the point isn't the end
come on big boy loosen your chaps
the point is winning
[Music]
people worry we're going to lose
everything what the firm
and the country oh
go let me have a drink or two before we
face that my god
[Music]
you you and you
[Music]
it was a conference call
i've just received intel that the
british power grid is failing
there are rolling outages in france
spain germany
[Applause]
something's wrong with the oil andy
system shut down
equipment failure they've never seen
anything like it
i need to do a full analysis
spectroscopy energy density everything
i'll get to the bottom of it
your son is having surgery and i will be
there
i need to do this i don't want you to
leave i'll be back i promise
planes are crashing and no one can see
why
the worst case is unfolding
the sophisticated attacks
everything will be impacted food
medicine electricity leading to mass
panic then violence
you think this is deliberate
chaos knows is the gravest danger
let's go let's go
your expertise makes you a target
you're not telling me something
there is a lot at stake here i need you
folks i don't know where my wife and
kids are
[Music]
once you've seen the truth
it becomes your responsibility to help
other people's hate too
we're going to do this together every
step of the way
just tell me what i've got to do
this is what we're up against this is
how everyone sees them as some kind of
philanthropist out to save the kids at
the valley terry silver
one of you guys named michael it's
michaela whatever i washed my hands at
copacaine when we lost a tournament i'm
not a sensei anymore
[Music]
as of today i am shutting down miyagido
karate this can't be your plan with
johnny gone it's on me to fix this
one star does a car smell like beer it's
because there is beer [ __ ]
cobra kai now has more students than
ever before
that means we'll need more senseis i'm
thinking a lot bigger than just the
value
everything was supposed to be better
after the tournament it's only getting
worse
i know how things can start out from
nothing and get bigger and bigger until
all you feel is hate
[Music]
i want you guys to get along we're all
friends now we're not friends we never
will be
silver's dividing and conquering if this
continues all that we have fought for
will not even be memory
i need you to see which of my students
are ready to take the next step
hold on you really won't stop you need
to let me and chosen handle this it's
the only way to make it all in fine
handle
it we got to do is get our hands dirty
if you continue down this path nothing
in your life will ever be the same again
[Music]
adult classes are on wednesday we're not
here to take a lesson
we're here to teach you one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm happy to hear that you're doing well
with the others
yeah well i make friends pretty easily
i find that a little kindness goes a
long way
[Music]
my story begins when i was a young girl
i was alone in the world
my first impression of my fellow man was
less than favorable
[Music]
it doesn't matter what you want your
marriage has been arranged
france accepts catherine de medici in
marriage with henry duke of orleans then
something terrible happened
i fell in love
but i was wrong
do you know what i learned that day
never trust a single soul
it was my time to govern
the only way i knew how
perhaps if we gave him the proper
incentive he would tell us the truth
cut off his finger
watford
[Applause]
[Music]
has a magician he has lured her over to
the dark house drake
you were cold possessed of the black
heart just as they say
sometimes it feels like i can make
things happen if i want them badly
enough
if you don't teach your enemies a lesson
then i'll never learn
[Music]
when you find life conspiring against
you
you must change it to your favor no
matter what the cost
are you with me
i am with you
none of us are safe
[Music]
you have a serpent in your midst
it was good to be bad
[Music]
he was a monster
the founding father of gilead
he took away our country
he had to pay for what he did
i killed him
and i loved it so much
[Music]
june tore him apart
i need her to know me
do you want her to come after us
there's no way that she could have
gotten to fred on her own stream doesn't
know what happened
doesn't matter what she knows
it matters what she believes
serena has the world behind her
she is bringing it here
dalian
my job is to protect you
tell me you can protect me from her
scare can be very dangerous
she will always be dangerous
i think he scared gilead as well
the handmaid killing her commander
i don't think they'll be able to let
that stand
june osborne is a cancer
we have to cut her out
there are consequences for disobeying
god
gilead wants to see us suffer just to
keep yourself safe
[Music]
everything we want to know about hannah
it's right there
they're not gonna be looking for
somebody going back into killian
i'm going
i'm going with you
[Music]
fear you're careful
she will pull you down with her
i pray for our children
may they live a life without all of this
hate
[Music]
dear god
may they do better than we did
[Music]
we all know the dangers that lurk
outside our gates
i want to do my sworn duty
i want to protect my best friend from
danger
[Music]
and i want a life to call my own i would
never bet against you rose hathaway you
should see me
you must prepare lissa for a new role as
the head of the dragon family and rose
she'll do her duty
i'm the royal princess that needs
protecting rose gives and gives and i
take and take
i can be a leader who ruled not just for
the voice but for all citizens
whether you wear the crown or not you
have the power to change things you
should see me in the crowd
there's
something
strange happening
i think i can help you
christian is a non-starter for a lot of
people
i'll be discreet of course i want to put
you first but i can't you can either be
guardian or friend not vote
what's the game plan you know me more of
a role with the punches kind of girl
the ruler is not just any monarch
leadership requires sacrifice for the
greater good
i need a fight
we need to fight
they must be willing to give everything
they have we deserve a better future
she's my family
i would die for her
[Music]
the last time we did this you guys gave
me room temp water and charged me extra
because it was sunny in atlanta come on
now i just wanna bad for you anyway
[Music]
you seem frustrated today i'm not upset
about anything hey man what's going on
i mean not the flex but work is good hey
i'm here to see d'angelo what you did up
there was very impressive so how did you
do that do what
[Music]
then all hell breaks loose
she sent me all the pretty pictures i
don't screen shot it like don't be
sending me the kitty if you ain't nobody
get off my car now oh my goodness
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i watch criminal minds and i know when
someone's up to something twisted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
espn
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
american ambassador melanie gibbons
[Music]
[Music]
individuals
[Music]
hey guys
[Music]
pretty spooky day today huh
sorry traffic was crazy yes demons
learning
[Music]
i thought it was a watermelon
goodnight cousin
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
anymore
[Music]
losing control is the best part
all my people in one place so can't
believe how lucky i am
your regime is gone
it's time to embrace the new one
[Music]
everything that's happening at alfie
saw my fault
you're a teenager
[Applause]
should be allowed to be
a teenager
your life is your life
you can live it how you want
[ __ ] everybody else
fairies from the school have started to
go missing
muslim was working on some super
mysterious [ __ ]
you really don't know the half of it
[Music]
magic
[Music]
love
fairies
will cease to exist
but things are more complicated than
they seem
you still don't know where you came from
welcome to my dark side
because that's not ominous at all
we have to do something
all of us working together
care to put your magic where your mouth
is
oh
i know we have lots of questions
it's how we deal after we're knocked
down that makes us bravo
this is how i go
you're the one i want looking over there
the navy destroyer uss crampton was hit
yesterday 20 sailors were killed in the
attack
robert will be deploying on a long-term
special activities up
not in syria who's there
who isn't
command's under pressure
one team is going to get decommissioned
our first op without clay
could be our last op ever
[Music]
bravo will be the only americans in
north syria
show up for war and a hello kitty
convention breaks out
my soldiers may not have your training
but they are feared fear
i think we can work with that
i made a bad call
claire is fighting for his life right
now because of me
we're still a family it doesn't change
when did bravo become a bomb magnet
we never discuss what doing this
together looks like maybe we should know
somebody messed up and they need to be
held accountable
what are you not telling me
[Music]
we cannot keep killing our way out of
this war
maybe a little mercy goes a long way
we're definitely on the lookout for
breakthrough shows so what do you got
i want to reboot the old sitcom step
right up
[Music]
are you serious and i want to do it with
the original cast according to wikipedia
clay barber drug charge and disorderly
conduct framerate jensen did a low
budget sci-fi cable show captain i'll
repair them as soon as i
nourish my larva and reed sterling left
to pursue a film career i'm the ruthless
mother standing here with a 38 snub nose
you know what
i was thinking what if i infused it with
a layer of weariness and vulnerability
maybe i don't think
which
is just not what they taught us at the
yale school of drama okay we're done
remember i told you they were rebooting
my old show is she gonna be there you
didn't mean brie i'm chugging i can't
breathe unhook this fine but i'm in a
committed relationship what are you 15 i
got it
i i thought it would be weird if uh the
first time we saw each other was on set
that would be weird
everyone this is gordon he is the
creator of the original show or new
writers this one of those diversity
intern training things uh literal gas
comedies evolved since you last wrote
for television i mean honestly whole
species have evolved that's what i'm
talking about come on guys let's bring
it in no reason to do that
your mom still comes to set with you
every day she's been coming to set with
me my whole life dude that's creepy
could you say something to my mom yeah
what the
you know how in the old sitcom the
characters always did the right thing
man they don't do the right thing
anymore
oh boy what if zach finds out runs what
up uh that i couldn't talk to your mom
yet too hard huh no no i wouldn't say
that not that
we gotta meet preemie jensen can we just
tape this later because honestly i'm
feeling really gross right now and
according to wardrobe i look like a cow
we're live to 85 000 people
hi everyone
hello
you actually have the rare gift of being
funny you can make millions of people
laugh to bring people a little joy yes
that is as good an honorable thing as a
man can do gordon i'm speechless [ __ ] if
i knew that's all it took i would have
complimented you years ago
i work at hulu this is my first time on
a set i'm new to humor what do you do
vice president of comedy
fun
[Music]
[Music]
to steal from the empire
you just walk in like you belong
[Music]
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
they can't imagine
that someone like me
[Music]
would ever get inside their house
chassis and antler
the empire is choking us so slowly
we're starting not to notice
what i'm asking is
wouldn't you rather give it all
to something real
[Music]
i need all the heroes i can get
for the greater good
call it what you will
let's call it
war
it's fermenting out there some
pockets of fermenting
you're in my net
are you a fish
or are you a thief
you're slipping
i'm not sleeping
i've just been hiding for too long
as long as everyone thinks i'm an
irritation
there's a good chance they'll miss what
i'm really doing what are you really
doing
this is what revolution looks
i'm like of losing
you